[Music]
what I said you know it's a hard time
they're celebrities
look I'll make sure they're still loved
through a recession it's that it really
it makes me laugh it does make me laugh
um everyone's everyone this new thing in
England is celebrities having depression
oh I feel all depressed it's always it's
always over privileged performers that
have these bouts of depression you don't
have blue-collar workers no
working-class mums with 60 of nothing I
feel a bit depressed do you get the kids
to school oh yeah you know I just think
of these guys on minimum wage reading
articles well I don't oh look at this
this port millionaire comedian he feels
all alienated I was there something I
could do but I lost my fingers I mean
please pull yourself together
everything's in addiction now as well
isn't it everything oh oh I was saying
the other night that if I come up on a
chat show and say I've never been a
heroin addict not a ripple of applause
if I come and go I used to do a lot of
arrowing and I used to steal and mug for
that I used to piss myself in doorways
but I haven't done that for a little
while they go oh he hasn't done those
things he should have been doing in the
first place for a little while
brilliant Oh God I'm addicted to sex not
a problem not a problem
shut up why you're telling me about it
why are you telling me why are you
calling your publicist before you call a
doctor addicted to sex Jesus Christ
Oh God I drink too much we'll stop then
stop then I mean it's doing you no good
at all Oh God so yeah I like to liver is
yep I got all my money at the bank and
bought a gun then I sit on it I sit on
it in my house look oh well I'm aware of
it of course I'm not going through the
the hardship of people less fortunate
but and now hasn't
[Music]